good afternoon
on friday my wife jill and i
had the honor of paying respects to
justice ginberg
and uh her family first woman
first woman in history of our nation to
lie and state
the u.s capitol and though
it should not have taken nearly this
long to bestow that honor
on a woman it nevertheless speaks to the
unique and powerful impact
justice ginsburg has made on our society
and her her enduring legacy of equal
rights and equal justice under the law
shortly before justice ginberg's passed
she she told her granddaughter and i
quote
my most fervent wish is that i will not
be replaced until a new president
is installed and a quote it wasn't a
personal request
it wasn't a favor being asked for
it was the last act of a long
unflinching career of standing
up for american democracy
never before in our nation's history has
the supreme court justice been nominated
and installed while a presidential
election
is already underway it defies
every precedent every expectation
of a nation where the people the people
are sovereign
and the rule of law reigns
but yesterday before justice ginsburg
could be laid to rest and after a
hundred thousands of americans
had already cast their ballots the
president nominated
a successor to her seat
it's no mystery about what's happening
here
president trump is trying to throw out
the affordable care act
he's been trying to do it for the last
four years
the republican party has been trying to
eliminate it
for a decade twice already
the stream the supreme court has upheld
that law
the affordable care act and the congress
expressing the popular will of the
american people has rejected
president trump's efforts as well
now all of a sudden
this administration believes they found
a loophole
in the tragedy of justice ginsburg's
death
it doesn't matter to them the
republicans set the precedent just four
years ago
when they denied even the courtesy of a
hearing to president obama's nominee
after justice scalia passed
after he had only passed away nine
months
prior to election day
didn't matter to them but millions of
americans already voting on a new
president
in the new congress had begun
all that does matter is that they see an
opportunity
to overturn the affordable care act
on their way out the door and as i
speak we are still in the midst of the
worst global health crisis in a century
a crisis has already taken over two
hundred thousand
lives between seven hundred and fifty
and a thousand lives a day
and counting and yet
the trump administration is asking the
supreme court right now
as i speak to eliminate the entire
affordable care act
the administration filed a brief in the
supreme court that concludes and i quote
the entire aca thus
must fall the entire
aca thus must fall
president trump can claim all he wants
is going to protect people with
pre-existing conditions
but the fact is he's already fighting to
take those protections away
as we speak if he has his way
more than 100 million people with
pre-existing conditions like
asthma diabetes and cancer
could once again be denied coverage
complications from covet 19
like lung scarring and heart damage
could become the next flood of
pre-existing conditions
used as an excuse to deny coverage
to millions of people women could once
again be charged
higher premiums just because they are
women
pregnancy becoming a pre-existing
condition again
seniors let's see the prescription drug
prices go up
and the funding for medicare go down
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter what
the american people want
president trump sees a chance to fulfill
his explicit mission
steal away the vital protections of the
aca from countless families
who've come to rely on them for their
health their financial security
the lives of those they love
president trump just tweeted an hour ago
on my way here
and i quote obamacare will be replaced
with a much
better and far cheaper alternative if it
is terminated in the supreme court
it would be a big win for the usa
it should come as no surprise that on
saturday
president trump would nominate judge amy
coney barrett
and on sunday lay out clearly
what his objective is to terminate
obamacare the judge is written
as a written track record written
tracker of disagreeing adamantly
with the supreme court's decisions on
two occasions upholding
the aca in fact
not as a judge but prior to going on the
bench she publicly criticized
chief justice roberts opinion upholding
the law
eight years ago
the american people understand the
urgency this moment
they're already voting in droves
because they know their health care
hangs in the balance
they understand that if donald trump
gets his way
they could lose the right to vote their
right to clean air and water their right
to equal pay for equal work
workers could lose their collective
bargaining rights
dreamers could be thrown out of the only
country they've ever known
and women could lose the bedrock rights
enshrined in roe v wade
for 50 years people are voting
right now because they know the very
soul of this country is at stake
and because they know that the decisions
of the supreme court
affect their everyday lives
their voices may not matter to donald
trump
they may not matter to mitch mcconnell
but there are senate republicans out
there who know in their hearts
they should but if they shut out the
voices of those
during a voting period during an
election
and closing the door on american
democracy thereafter
this is where the power of the nation
resides in
the people in the rule of law
in precedence we abide by to subvert
both openly and needlessly
even as americans cast their vote
would be an irreversible step toward the
brink
and a betrayal of a single quality
that america has borne and built on
the people decide
senate has to stand strong for our
democracy
they must not act on this nomination
until the american people finish the
process they're already begun
of selecting their president and their
congress
they've said before if the people choose
donald trump
then the senate should give his nominee
a hearing
and a vote if people do not choose trump
and choose me
president trump's nomination should be
withdrawn
i should nominate chosen by
a president who's just been elected and
by the people
to get a fair hearing which would not
even occur
until early february a confirmation vote
the u.s concert constitution provides
one chance one for the americans to have
their voices heard
on who serves a lifetime appointment on
the supreme court
who makes those big decisions about
their health care
their civil rights and much else that
chance is now
that moment is now and the voters in my
view are not going to stand for this
abuse of power
and if we're to call ourselves a
democracy their voices
must be heard
i urge the american people to keep
voting
to let your current senators know that
you want to be heard before
a vote on confirmation of a new justice
i urge every senator to take a step back
from the brink
take off the blinders of politics for
just
one critical moment and stand up for the
constitution
you swore to uphold
this is a time to de-escalate to put an
end
to the shattering of precedence that's
thrown our nation in the chaos under
this president
just because you have the power to do
something doesn't absolve you of your
responsibility
to do right by the american people
uphold
your constitutional duty summon your
conscience
stand up for the people stand up for our
cherry system of
checks and balances americans are
watching
americans are voting we must listen to
them
now we must
we must allow them to exercise this
sacred power
so please listen thank you
may god bless america may god protect
our troops
and i'll take a few questions yes
republicans sir they force judge
barrett's nomination through
and confirm they should see to it that
the american public will vote on the
senate races
in this election and they'll vote
republicans out of office
that's the consequence that's the focus
that's why i want to make it clear and
stay on message here
the clear focus is this is about your
health care
this is about whether or not the aca
will
exist this is about whether or not
pre-existing conditions
will be continued to be covered this is
about
whether or not a woman can be charged
more for the same procedure as a man
this is about people's health care in
the middle of a pandemic
yes you asked me one question fire away
no i have not i i concluded that that
would
put them in a position if they were to
vote the right way that they'd be
compromised because i called them
and so but i know and i have great
respect for a number of my republican
colleagues my former republican
colleagues
and uh i'm hoping they will do the right
thing
he's almost no i have no comment
yes
i am not and i i i know you're going to
be upset with my answer
but what i'm not going to do is play the
trump game
which is a good game he plays take
your eye off the issue before us if i
were to say yes or no to that
that becomes a big issue that's the
headline here
i am focused on one thing right now and
i really mean it
i'm focused on making sure the american
people understand
that they're being cut out of this
process they're entitled to be part of
and the cutout designed in order
to take away the aca and your health
care
in the midst of a pandemic that's the
focus
that's what it's on and that's the deal
thank you all so very very
much thank you
what do you what do you feel like you
have to accomplish to be successful on
tuesday what
just tell the truth thank you
you